sono i dottori non ho bisogno della
ruota delle sorprese delle torture
estreme questa volta sono estreme e
prato in più abbiamo tantissime sorprese
non sono finite qua sotto abbiamo
tantissime sorprese e non vedo l'ora di
fare l'unboxing spenda perché mancano le
sorprese perché lo vedo l'ora di aprirla
l'inter in un'area il mio libro
bellissimo libro è ancora scontato su
amazon
mi state inviando le vostre foto visto
diciamo che mi sta piacendo tantissimo i
tre felicissimo perché ci abbiamo messo
il cuore in quest'edizione ci piace
tantissimo
vi lascio il link in descrizione se
volete comprarlo anche voi iscrizione
per prenderlo a newton scontato se non
lo trovate in tutte le librerie certi
cioè iniziamo anche degli oggetti di
cioccolato
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e fortuna mi è capitato se posso
scegliere io addio 38 passato abbiamo un
sacco di cose ci facciamo certo questo
che da un tacco che lo vogliamo aprire è
uno squeeze i unicorno e ne possono
capitare tanti narrati mangiati tutti
quelli che possono capitare io spero che
vi capiti quello moglie aline questi
figlio tema non diretto questo viola
abitare piace quella viola a me quello
per le ali nere vediamo finalmente posso
aprirlo stava spezzato pubblica tedesca
che non esisterà l'accusa il verde
inizialmente mi avete fermo non è
proprio verde e tipo verde ati piccoli
acquisti ricordo allora il team è la fa
scrissi strisce profumata si chiama
plastica lange scritto come si chiama
hai capito tantissimi più bello iniziata
bene questa challenge
[Musica]
oggi ci credo una penitenza ma a turno
allora ti capita dall'osso rai quindi
questa la rossa che la marina boxing
affetto ok unboxing la pizzica vita
secondo me chi capita
credetemi commenti e con vitale che
servizi camporini altezze armiere dall 8
all 11 ottobre il 20 nel cloud si vuol
dire ci stiamo avvicinando per quel che
dice almost quasi arrivati non sono
riuscito a farla correttamente sventrata
vabbè si ricordi che poiché gli stessi
frequentatori fra i poli si pone
diamante quadrifoglio diavoletto fuoco e
ghiaccio pioggia il sole e con troppo
e al primo gli altri non vuol dire che
quello che mi già aperta questo perché
non mi hai detto prima che lo ha detto
capello
l'ultima sentito prima
e allora spetta prima di aprirla l'on
l'assassino struggendo fatta prima di
aprirla non apriamo prima gli aggettivi
vediamo se riusciamo a dominare sono sì
c'è una meglio vedo chi era il nome
[Musica]
perfetto di bianchi è un cult i glitter
forse quello che dovrebbe essere morti
del mago di oz agitato
io spero sempre verso poi possono da
mangiare non segna ma è in quel modo è
già chi lo avevi già staccata la testa
una volta di depressione adesso c'è
scritto per rimuovere parlare per
rimuovere questo sarcofago devi prima
chiamata è stato e ora la prontissima
marino
ma come si chiama preparare poi troppo
detto oddio ma è a controllo estero
attesta che impressione non trova la
bambola questo è il castore cd story
book club tutti dai vesti l'ha
dimenticato ci vediamo come la fece bene
ci sarà sta dicendo mestiere la
tombolini incredibile forse bisognava
metterlo prima questo che è capitata
perfezione il vestito nero dentro matto
quando ti vesti titoli notte terminati
maglioni di solito si fa niente le
scarpe che carine stupidissima brava
quindi io finora ho uno spizzico vediamo
chi prenderà le prime penitenze possiamo
ancora nessuna verità insomma che
fortuna aree qualcosa tra le sorprese a
occhi chiusi non tra le penitenze
prendono sono chiusi da allora abbiamo
dei bustoni pieri di conte e qui
io sono gli occhi vado a pescare
ciao mista che prendo la cosa più grande
[Applauso]
prigione caldissimo tambure tamburello
si chiama non solo da un buio o
tamburello per fortuna non è capitato a
me perché altrimenti conigliette di
bambi e mila finora che speciale sta
andando benissimo paura perché vuol dire
che magari sono iniziati capiteranno
tutti e tira abiteranno tutt'assieme
[Musica]
primo mini testa è capitata mentale e
neri mangiare un limone magari mi fa
bene questo malato è vero
40 non so perché solo sentire l'odore
mi chiamo e iscriversi anche quelli come
te anche se non sentite non lo so non
vedendolo diviene titolo st lee masters
e sì a me sapremo cosa molto forti stili
mondo tra i servita che falso si sa che
per questo brand
[Applauso]
qualcuno buono dai modo molto saporito
ventimiglia del bellissimo si era
beccato la prima per i testa ora tocca
ammetto che a me è molto forte un altra
un altro compreso allora in questo caso
il regalino è a scelta lo il testo
quindi volta offrendo però perché
milanese sospettare un sacco di tempo
per aprirla l'altro ce n'è anche un
altro gol
vediamo un po come si fa dentro
l'oggetto delle l'on
il cioccolato è diverso da quello kinder
la guardia comentarios 30 poco buon vi
diamo veloce nella sua preda
ma belli ci sono due fermacapelli delle
lor
cosa stai facendo ai suoi cari notissimo
smettila smettere di mangiare di
nascosto
quando io sto mangiando di nascosto
proprio fermacapelli possono kharafi di
novi giocato come sempre domani di nato
facciamo bene a tutti gli usi allora io
tutti gli usi voglio comici 3600
orecchie e gli occhi come faccio io di
no ma è un regalo così troppo sono fatto
questa fermata dai più i giochi pesca
borsellino e fassa milano con i soldi
dentro ho fatto molto bene mi fai peak è
carinissimo il maialino di toy story e
ti somiglia anche guerra metterò a
fianco alla tua forza
a messina ti devi mettere una monetina
ogni volta che non mi rubi da mangiare
quindi sto già in partita quindi non
metterei mai entrato in moneta in meno
[Musica]
altro regalo obama passano sempre più
forti i dati in questa notte come questi
ben a volte è meglio che ha avuto l'ok
al neon e allora devo scegliere un altro
regalino
ma saviano stone base
da allora ha scelto
non tocca a me tasse di topolino e
quindi trovo né per me allora sì hai
visto che brava siamo proprio noi perché
tu sei colpi topolino o dire ma io punto
di visto le altre cane maialino camilo
topolino tutti sono al contrario che
però non si baciano
ecco allora che cai
[Musica]
graziati di struggente canto momento non
aiuta certo il movente contenti hanno
detto che non si buttano ha già aperto
guardare anche qui ci sono le pretese
identiche a quelle capelli
basta era compatto sei contento sono
bellissimo anche simone basta tutto male
[Musica]
penitenza è la prima presidenza tra
l'altro quindi 2 taiwo buono di tutte le
botte
ecco l'altro no ne stai mangiando un
quarto è senza buccia quindi dovremmo
andare pure l'altra
ma da buon o se l'equazione dai dopo di
commentare un pezzo di cioccolato ai me
lo domando allora l'altro mangiare anche
l'altro buon appetito
buono sì ma con un po ti senti ti fa
bene vitamina c
così almeno non ti ammali vede rifiuti e
io mai toccate ballo
[Musica]
tuttavia italiani ma anche tu così
impari
ti prego faccia cioccolato il problema
tocca a mister niente luna l'olio e con
no no io stavo sperando che quella fosse
l'unica che non sarebbe mai capitata con
la mia mente è ovvio red
questo l'ho fatto io no non lo voglio
mollare devi sentire tu sia buttata
certo scappiamo penso mi vuoi mangiare
la devi essere tu e io non ti posso dire
niente
vediamo vediamo
quando mi piace tanto piedi quale quello
di si nasconderà via drago aiuto poi
tutto il cattivissimo giulio cercato di
scappare ed hanno avuto le mollettine
lolek e di mangiare roll ha fatto c'è un
bagno perché vedo dello slam in forno è
vero come rino mi ha passato di tutti i
colori era anche quella che è stata
inversione lo slime per le penitenze
povera tagliamo facciamo soltanto di
capelli ed il quale va data gli altri
magari ti tagliamo un pochettino sotto
traversi così chi ha già tagliato i
capelli qui magari condannato pino
estivo dell'anno po di capelli o di no
ma carina così i capelli più corti
adesso li facciamo con la mia figlia mi
dedico ai capelli stop e di un altro
taglio un catino abbiamo l'acqua sembra
normale poi in tv ci togliamo un po la
frangetta comico delle posizioni dentro
la testa a testa vuota e permettere però
attaccato abbraccio una cosa nera
andiamo a vedere chi voleva tagliare con
la frangetta viene arriviamo un pochino
la frangetta la chiesa troppo bassa ma
chi sei
addio a favore che parte per il bene
dell etica perché ne tagliata a fini
[Musica]
credi che tocca rito con la fronte un po
più alta che vede più forte anche di là
dove di porto di qua e porto di qua e
anche dietro la paura
mai come adesso è bellissimo adesso
[Musica]
andiamo pure a metano dalle questo non
si taglia troppo dura dobbiamo proprio
con alice una busta nera varia forse lo
slime aveva fatto strage la corte il
centro addio che strana questa cosa
perché così il buco della prossima per
quando sfrutta tipo serbatoi e quindi
avrà rappresento lo slime dentro io
sempre in testa un nuovo taglio di
capelli tra provocano carcere qui adesso
li mettiamo in una scheda fa aveva paura
che sull olio vedere che verrà a
trovarci tar o tesi taglierà i capelli
sono vero visto che bella addio
[Musica]
e adesso mi mangio cioccolato verrà
trovarti stanotte e ti taglierà tutti
caffè e le orecchie
[Musica]
nella maggiore ed è allora togliamo di
tutti non ci pensa più a nessuno
spuntatina che attacca ancora non
abbiamo tolti devo stare un pochino più
attento
vi lasciamo solo questi rossi che ne va
insieme e abbiamo fatto a pelata con la
stessa usata almeno mi hai lasciato la
faccia più c'era un prezzo della faccia
perché un po triangolare e più carino no
ma mi fa paura questa notte non lo
voglio più vedere
non la voglio vedere festività
carinissimo guarda sto meglio e la metto
a fianco al letto per prima cosa capelli
come potevano così è contento la tua
ancora tante volte
bene fa molto mi ha dato più male a me
perché metterebbe gli ascolti sono stati
o sono tagliato un po i capelli sono
stati scoperti sono per il limone questo
sofferenza più grande però che con la
loro terre a tutta forza questo non si
trovava come ho avuto uno squisito uno
squisito dico non lo sapevo che si
giravano a tre gambe si è prenotabile ho
scoperto solo adesso è diventata la
bambola assassina che si perseguiterà
durante la notte
poi abbiamo le tue tasse di minnie
topolino realtà ce n'erano altri breve
io c'ho la nonna e il maialino
salvadanaio cammino è proprio il
cioccolato che questo finito ormai anzi
no aspetta definito da mia mamma mi ha
fatta non lo metto più il cioccolato è
secondo tutto scrivete nei commenti se
volete ciò con la situazione coperti
cioccolata cosa da mangiare a utilizzo
di medicine commenti che altre penitenze
estreme e che anche le sorprese volete
che mettiamo nella ruota della fortuna
sfortuna o ruota della benedizione del
match
scriveteci tutti i vostri suggerimenti
nei commenti di tales esser con 8 su con
atto no perché ho avuto blatta sono
basati leggono è mai accaduto che vi
leggo da ti faccio uscire con le
mollettine delle lol benissimo insomma
tutti i vostri suggerimenti nei commenti
lasciate un bella ex questo video
sentitissimi likes faremo un altro
episodio della ruota delle pendenze e
delle sorprese io ora devo controllare
vitale perché sta per mangiarsi col
cioccolato
adesso puoi cliccare le altre challenge
anche le altre
peccato sapere libero sono la canzone
preferita
buona visione